[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
nine perfect strangers episode six
motherlode this was written by jessica
scharzer and jonathan levine and like
every episode is directed by jonathan
levine so this episode actually starts
with a disclaimer warning about really
sensitive content that's to do with
mental health issues and suicide so
going to this review and be talking
about a lot of heavy stuff so just a
warning and you know when i saw that as
a viewer i got scared that that meant
something's gonna happen with tony
because last episode said he didn't know
if you make it through the week so that
really kind of scared me just going into
it you always kind of your head starts
to ravel like oh where are they going
with this but let's break down why they
gave that warning and what really went
on here so it opens with masha here
having a temporary break in her
perfectionist ways eating some of this
birthday cake what she is imagining her
head is hers little girl eating a cake
so it's cool they do this because it's
brought up later by delilah to her and
that delilah saw her and that there's
this little girl inside that masha still
suppresses as much of a free spirit
masha is she suppresses her inner child
in a lot of ways and that's by
suppressing and giving herself things
that feel good and trying to be almost
too perfectionist and it's kind of
showing that flaw a bit which i thought
was effective but what we see in this
episode compared to the last episodes
last episode was all about building the
relationships between everybody and
really making them close with this we
knew the dose was going to go even
higher but it's really an episode about
now really getting to the core of
everyone's problems and really facing
head-on there are traumas where it
wasn't as intense let's say with like a
francis or lars this episode with that
and it's really the marconi family where
we're gonna see the intensity and why
there's a warning before this episode so
we get this odd sequence though with
francis and she sees paul and he's this
tiny version of himself singing you know
bragging about all the money she gave
him and he got away with and that it's
not really his son it's his cousin's son
and she ends up flushing it on the
toilet it was strange though you know i
don't know if it really hit humorously
for me but that's personal taste uh
seeing him dance with the q-tip i was
like okay i don't know i didn't think it
was that funny or great to be honest i
think the show sometimes could be too
obsessed with knowing it's muslim
mccarthy playing francis that she is
known more for comedy and that they kind
of feel like maybe they have to write
comedy in all of her scenes where maybe
just let her do her thing you know i
think it's too forced that way but we
see lars is having nightmares himself
about being called a slur here from the
past that happened with schoolyard
bullies and mash is just there watching
him which is creepy but she's explaining
that she knows what he's going through
and he'll explain to zoe in the next
scene that you know she's controlling
them through the dreams through drugs
and audio and a bunch of things so it's
a little confusing but that's kind of
the gist of it and the point of that
scene though really is masha giving him
this camera which is on the phone that's
not connecting instagram is like this is
your chance to be the one who tells the
world like giving him this like pump up
like hey document all this now because
stuff's going to get crazy and you can
get some credit here it's kind of that
kind of pull which is interesting and
it's going to be interesting where lars
goes with this and how far he'll go even
with masha and documenting all this so
where we get this big twist is after the
scene where we learn they're upping
everyone's dose but masha makes clear
this time it's with consent that they
don't have to take it but she knows
they're going to right because again
these are people all struggling and
they're kind of all on board right now
but carmel goes to masha probably
because she's the one resisting to that
a bit she's worried like we hear in the
episode that if she sees her ex she's
not gonna have the same reaction that
francis did she'll literally stab that
person if she hallucinates her ex right
because she staggered them with a fork
before so what the twist is here is that
when she sees masha we learn the big
twists here from masha her saying to
carmel i know why you came here you came
to retreat because i had an affair with
your husband so this is a game changer
what i like about it being the character
of caramel that is the one we learned
this twist about is that she's the most
dangerous already she's already kind of
been developed that way or she could
break any moment and you could see the
fear in mash's eyes even around carmel
like are you trying to kill me and she's
addressing that maybe you're the one
threatening me now regina hall as carmel
has just blown me away in this
performance that continues it's a
complete performance that's fully deep
into the character here she is caramel
it's incredible you see it all on her
face too and she's like i came here to
know you to see what he saw on you and
that you were a catalyst to all this but
you know she says we're in love i came
here to study you in the hopes of
becoming you and then he might want me
back so it's really sad it's hard to
hear but she's kind of looting too like
well if you knew this you know masha why
did you even accept me here and she's
saying it's to heal her and help her and
that she can trust her you know and you
know she's like i would never hurt you
so we know mash is a liar her character
and really good characters like matcha
types lie a lot you have to remember
that and they put this creepy music
behind her purposely to kind of
subconsciously remind us that you can't
trust this woman and her hugging karma
like it's gonna be okay i'm gonna take
care of you something's gonna split
there i'm still making a big prediction
now that caramel is gonna be the undoing
of masha at some point especially
because they keep bringing up that if
she was to see hallucination ever
actually might actually hurt somebody
with a fork i think it will actually be
masha that's my prediction i haven't
read the book so again no book spoilers
anywhere please but i can also say you
know you can put into oh who's the man
who shot masha with the white eyeball
that might be carmel's ex-husband you
know it would make sense so we'll see
and we'll have to learn more about again
whoever this man is at shot mancha the
why now what i liked about the directing
lot this episode is levine has proven
that he is very good at directing scenes
that make you feel like you are in a
high dosage of psychedelics and that
really hits here when everyone's sitting
around in the retreat and francis is
just so out of it and that's a tribute
to the actors too and she just walks
outside when she shouldn't and then
tony's got to follow her i thought that
whole scene was shot so well the way he
presents it's really effective in
setting the mood and making you feel
like what they're feeling now what i'm
saying i feel like the writers really
want to give melissa mccarthy a lot of
humor to work with i actually think it
did actually work here though when she's
in this moment with tony and he's about
to kiss her and she said oh my god he's
going in i thought that was actually
pretty funny and she's like i said that
out loud so that was realistic too
that's something that would kind of
happen in that kind of moment you
believe it that that's frances and tony
in that kind of interaction but it's
also a very light scene when they
finally kiss because
it's setting up a for you know more of
another dark monologue from tony but
again the darker second half that
focuses on the marconi family but to
that point about tony here when he's
talking about you ever think about not
going on now this would have hit way
harder to me when he goes on this speech
to francis which actually ends up being
a positive note at the end of what he
says but maybe not show us last episode
that he had already mentioned this that
he was not sure if he's gonna make it
another week and he did have the
suicidal tendencies why show that last
week if you're just going to have him
kind of reveal that here that might have
hit hard if he found out that now and
then he reveals that no this place is
saving me from that like he said he's
thinking about even taking her out to
dinner thinking about getting a dog so
he's healing and what i like is that he
acknowledges that yeah i know mash is
using us basically and that it is this
cult like thing and he's drinking the
kool-aid but he's like it's working like
he's in so i thought that was a really
well-written scene except the point
again of maybe last week they should
have dropped that scene with him talking
to francis i don't think it was
necessary so a random scene that happens
this episode we don't get much time
anymore with jessica ben relationship
which is a little disappointing because
again i'm a huge samara weaving fan so i
thought this scene was really cool
though because it's the most horrifying
scene we've seen yet in bringing the
horror aspect where she breaks the
golden rule jessica of being on
psychedelics and looking in the mirror
obviously that can make you have too
many self-reflective thoughts and she's
somebody who has self-image issues so of
course she's going to look deeply find
something wrong with her and she sees
her nose fall off very horrifying this
scene i thought it was interesting you
wish maybe they got more meat at this
point jessica and ben but for the time
they gave it i did think it was
effective and truly scary so let's jump
into the really heavy stuff here and
this is gonna happen with the marconis
and it starts because we're seeing the
connection from last episode where masha
says to zoe you are the key so what she
means by that is she's the key to her
ultimate long-term plan about again
having such heavy psychedelic
experiences that you're literally
hallucinating someone and getting to
this alternate reality where you could
actually recreate living with them and
that she's a believer you can keep
pushing this and zoe's someone who is
very sensitive to that that she does see
the hallucinations more than anybody in
this show and especially of zack and you
know i i did really like how they shot
this again very disturbing but the way
they did it where when zoe's going in
the woods and she doesn't even see it
but the audience sees it with zach
hanging behind her and then when she's
talking his acne appears in front of her
it perfectly set the mood seeing the
hanging behind her again realizing how
dreary this tragedy was for his family
but then it being her mom she's really
talking to she thinks it's zach it's
really effective how they shot all this
like i'm saying how olivine is doing
really good with these type of sequences
that are very trippy but you see that
napoleon sees zach and then heather c
zak and this is a shared psychosis
hallucination which masha explains later
is just something that's so rare so this
is like a big win in mash's book that
this even happened and what this episode
does so well is it showing you how
messed up this is getting but masha
again even though she can say she cares
about them that's the debate the other
day if she really does or not and that
she does really want to heal people or
is it just for her own self you know
goals here to be the healer but does she
really care about the people she's
healing because she talks to people and
treats them behind the scenes like lab
rats but i want to just give again
standout scene here i haven't talked
about the actress much and i should be
talking about her more as asher kitty
here's just so many great actors and
actually the show so trying to give
everyone their credit but she stands out
in this episode for me and this moment
it's so heartbreaking she's like i want
to know why she says to zach he brings
up the asthma medication and that
there's a side effect of suicidal
ideation and he's like you underline it
so it's confirming that she did
underline it she knew about it and this
is the reason for her guilt that she
feels like she had her son was killed
because of her and clearly in her
storyline for the show we've only seen
you know hints that she's got serious
issues but not to the extent of what's
really beneath it all and now we're
seeing that like she's suppressed this
thought in her head that she has this
guilt so now it's coming out what i also
liked is what they're doing with delilah
a lot in this show so like after heather
bugs out here and just like collapses
it's reminiscent of the collapse that we
saw delilah experienced of someone that
was there before which we'll learn later
episode is and we can assume this family
they're talking about the connors who
she thinks is the ones threatening masha
and that there was legal troubles from
them what happened and that this isn't
the first time asha's tried this extreme
thing it seems like with a family so
delilah's getting like triggered here
and she's like okay this can't be
happening again but delilah's reacting
to it like a normal person would that
you know these people need help she
might need to go to a hospital but
masha's like relax relax you know masha
again her number one thing is getting
what she needs and that her plan will go
fine it's not the needs of others even
though she might try to appear that way
because she even says to zoey here i'm
sorry for this but this need to happen
she had to have this memory come back
because again it is the ultimate thing
she needs to see work and her test of
like am i finding this cure-all for
these people suffering and then i could
you know sell it to others now i loved
the hardest i've left on the show yet
actually happened to be
when francis is in the pool with
everybody and she just says anyone else
still wearing the shoes i still have my
shoes and i thought muscle mccarthy of
course she's always great at comedic
delivery and this was just perfect i
laughed out loud at that now i'll take a
deep dive here and say that and that's
no pun intended here but there's a lot
of symbolism to me with this pool scene
where you know no one's really supposed
to be swimming and i look at this water
and pulling the scene as like that's
masha you know that's what masha's
serving them and her way is this pool
because tony's resisting it because he
knows it's bad but then they convince
him to go in and he likes it all the
ones in there we know are on mash's
vision right now which lars jessica ben
francis and tony going in even though he
resists a lot now he's in they're all in
on it but you see carmel has her feet in
the pool not fully in and this is
exactly how we keep seeing car more
she's back and forth with everything
that's going on you can't really read
her and delilah's the one coming in to
tell them to get out which is what she's
slowly been trying to do with this whole
thing and then you know that even though
they feel like everything's going great
they're loving being in that pool the
reality of it is the people they're like
where's heather in the marconis they're
in urgent care so this is the reality of
the situation what really happens if you
go down and drink the kool-aid as they
say and that would be the pool for me
with masha that's how i kind of see it
but maybe i'm overthinking that a line
that confused me and i don't have
subtitles unfortunately on these
screeners i get sent so i'd love some
help in the comments if someone can kind
of verify what happened here because i
couldn't i literally had my ear to the
thing and i couldn't make out zach says
to zoey here when she goes back into the
woods to talk to him and he's like i can
only tell people what they already know
he's like i can tell you and what i
think he said is to her you heard that
you'll be okay so is he talking about
she overheard you know heather say that
to him once or is he saying you're hurt
you'll be okay or you heard what i said
before i don't know it's such an
important line but i literally could not
make it out so someone can confirm that
down below that'd be great so again
where we get to the nitty gritty here
with the marconis is that napoleon's
saying like hey you know i used to blame
myself for this and because of that i
fully expected heather to leave me and
also blame me but he's like now the
shoe's on the other foot so he's like i
i'm a forgiving man and i can't forgive
this that he's also blaming heather as
she's already blaming herself about what
happened to zack and the big key here is
mash is saying to him what do you want
and he's like i just want my son back
and she's like i can arrange that so
when we go to see now heather with
napoleon and masha at this fireplace you
know heather's like i killed my son so
we're in the mindset of heather where
she's blaming herself and then napoleon
is blaming heather and it's terrible
grief they have and this is something
that most people like the points they
never resolve and a marriage just splits
over this but this is where masha is
gonna sound like cult leaders we know in
the past and she's talking about you
know you can be reunited with your son
and it's through psychedelics and it
makes sense that at first you know
napoleon's really resistance to this
because it does sound like ridiculous
and it's basically something you would
hear like any drug cult would eventually
pitch to get something like this but
over this convincing masha does and how
good she's convincing people and what
she's selling she's by the end of this
seems like she convinces heather and
that napoleon probably will come that
way because again the other day she
knows like she's saying this is like
unbearable grief for two people and this
is a way to face the trauma and do it
together and heal you know if they're
that desperate why wouldn't they at that
point you know and she knows that that's
why she picked these people but
important again delilah sees this and
that will go that scene with yeah where
delilah's like you know this is no good
i don't want to be complicit in this is
going too far we're going to have the
same incident like last time but yeah
still on the fence here and he still
sees the vision of masha so it's causing
even divide between those two but also
an important line that was in this scene
with masha and the marconi is that masha
says heather i know pain and i also know
healing put yourself in my hands don't
try to give your son back it's important
because by the end of episode i get the
big reveal that she lost her daughter to
a car accident and that she still has
that trauma flash so she's not even
fully seems like healed and faced her
trauma herself so that's interesting but
it's not the most exciting cliffhanger
at this point i don't know why i just
didn't hit for me uh i just was like oh
okay so she has trauma which we expected
but you know it's something we've seen
done a billion times with like a kid was
hit by a car and that's something that
they're hiding like i feel like i've
seen that a lot recently there's also
this odd scene they did quickly with
francis and carmel and francis says the
worst thing you could say to someone
like carmel like everyone seems to be
improving but i don't know why you don't
like why would you say that to carmel
that was just strange and silly to say
that because she that could just set her
off but yeah i was still a little
confused as to why francis kind of said
that because it seemed like in that
scene that caramel was sounding actually
better so i was like didn't make a lot
of sense to me seemed a little
convenient you know it's so strange
though overall this episode i'm very
conflicted about it like i said there's
a lot of patience needed last week
because of relationship building right a
lot of character work here i was
predicting that you know stuff was gonna
start hitting the fan it sort of does
but it also sort of doesn't if that
makes sense especially the first half
and it's still going at a very slow pace
that we're already at episode six
there's only two episodes left in a
limited series so i wish the other day
there was more entertainment value to be
had here that they do these great
storylines and characters in a plot that
moves a little quicker and get you a
little more hooked because right now i'm
into it but you know i'm not blown away
and i'm not saying there's nothing i can
really even like pinpoint i don't like
this episode i think it all is pretty
good but there's nothing in it that i go
wow like this was amazing and now i'm
really hooked or feeling into it and
connected i do think these themes work
and there's tough things they're dealing
with here that speak really well i'm
just saying that when you put like the
coding on it you know put it also in a
plot that's a little more moving quicker
interesting and keeping you invested in
the show where the other day i think
it's just making itself as a show that
we'll remember for being good with
characters and relationships but not the
greatest most interesting plot at the
moment but i'm gonna give this one an
8.2 and that is for the again strong
character work themes dealing with dark
stuff really well but just not feeling
it entertainment wise you know i just
feel like by this point we should be
moving along a little quicker here and
again it's tough because you have so
many characters and you got to fill all
these mouths but some are just feeling
underfed now and in particular jessica
and ben you know i felt like maybe even
the tony francis scenes so they got so
much time last week maybe there was just
too much with them here maybe too long
so and some beats seem like they're
repeating a bit like i said with tony
mentioning again about thinking he might
not make it another day we already heard
that last episode so it was kind of
retread but let me know what you thought
down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment try to
respond as many as i can please
subscribe if you like what i do here it
helps me so much and if you love what i
do here i'd appreciate you decide to be
a member it helps me so much it would
just get my dream to come true where i
could do this full time one day make
more reviews for you guys and you get
exclusive perks as well so check it out
with that join button below please
follow me at stevenshow on twitter
instagram for more of me and i'll see
you next time